why do you think pear that that women
are not natural leaders I just think
there are things that women are
naturally good at and men are naturally
good at women just tend to be more
agreeable and the trait disagreeability
men tend to be more that way where women
tend to be more agreeable you forgotten
margar fer and Liz trust and various
other Prime Ministers we well if you
want to look at women in positions of
political power they're actually more
violent and more willing to wage war so
I actually think that women do struggle
in positions of political power as well
for examp example your shortest prime
minister ever here was a woman